AND THE UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND A 1973 MEMORANDUM
AND UNDER THE CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION THAT YOU MUST NOT
AND CANNOT INDICT THE SITTING
PRESIDENT.
IT IS A MATTER OF CONSTITUTIONAL
INTERPRETATION AND 44 YEARS THAT
IS THE POSITION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND WE HAD LAW PROFESSORS AND
ALL OVER THE TV AND RADIO
TALKING ABOUT THE OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE AND MEDIA TYPES TALKING
ABOUT IT.
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER, THE
OFFICIALSTITION OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, WE DON'T CHARGE
A SITTING PRESIDENT WITH
A CRIME.
>> Sean: MARK LEVIN, THE GREAT
ONE ON OUR PROGRAM AND HE WORKED
AD EDNIECE CHIEF OF STAFF AND HE
WAS ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
EXPLAINING DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
POLICY.
MARK BROKE IT RIGHT HERE.
JOINS US NOW AND HOST OF LCH
LIBERTY AND LEVIN.
AND HOW ARE YOU, MY FRIEND?
I AM GETTING TICKED OFF BECAUSE
YOU ARE RIGHT.
BIG NEWS, THEY CAN'T INDICT
A SITTING PRESIDENT.
NO KIDDING.
YOU HAVE SAID IT OVER A YEAR.
WE POINTED IT OUT REPEATEDLY.
THE MEDIA GOT THE ASPECTS OF
THIS WRONG AND IGNORED THE REAL
WRONG AND A PUCE OF POWER AND
BEEN ON A WITCH HUNT GOING ON
OVER A YEAR.
AND TO ME.
THIS HAS TO COME TO AN END AND
SOME TRUTH NEEDS TO COME OUT.
SIR?
>> THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION HAS
REVEAL WOULD THE GREATEST
PEPITATOR AGAINST THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WAS THE GOVERNMENT AND
WAS THE FBI, CIA, AND NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE DIRECTOR.
>> Sean: TOP RANK AND FILE.
>> I WANT TO TAKE IT TO THE NEXT
LEVEL.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WILL NOT BE INDICTED AND
IF HE IS, HE WILL TAKE IT TO THE
SUPREME COURT AND WIN.
WE CANNOT ALLOW THIS TO HAPPEN
AGAIN.
WE SAW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
USED BY THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION
AND HEAD OF THE CIA AND FBI AND
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE AND MANY,
MANY OTHERS USED TO DESTROY THE
CANDIDACY OF AN OPPOSITION
CANDIDATE OF THE OTHER PARTY,
DONALD TRUMP AND THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
THOO THAT IS, THE PRESIDENT'S
EXISTING ADMINISTRATION AND
INTERFERING IN THE ELECTIONS AND
WE NEVER SAW THIS BEFORE IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
WE KNOW THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION SPIED, LOOK, IT
IS IT THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
AND HE'S THE PRESIDENT AND THE
BUCK STOPS AT HIS DESK AND HE
MAY BE PLAYING AROUND HIS
LIBRARY IN CHICAGO AND HE IS BE
HELD RESPONSIBLE.
THE FISA COURT FAILED US.
WE HAVE NATIONAL SECURITY
LETTERS THAT ARE USED IN EXTREME
CIRCUMSTANCES BEING USED AND
A FBI AGENTS THAT TOOK IT UPON
THEMSELVES TO INVESTIGATE
A CANDIDATE AND HIS CAMPAIGN AND
ACTUAL SPIES IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
WHAT IS IT?
THE SOVIET UNION OR VENEZUELA OR
CENTRAL AMERICA?
IT IS THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
ONCE MR. MUELLER TURNS OVER THE
REPORT TO MR. ROSENSTEIN.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD PICK
FAVORITE UNITED STATES ATTORNEY.
NOT BECAUSE THEY ARE PALS.
BUT GIVE HIM AN ASSIGNMENT.
I DON'T CARE WHAT JEFF SESSIONS.
AND TELL HIM.
I WANT YOU TO INVESTIGATE THE
ACTIVITIES THAT TOOK PLACE IN
THIS ELECTION AND LET THE CHIPS
FALL WHERE THEY MAY.
AND THE INNERFERRANCE BY THE FBI
AND CIA AND NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE.
AND BRENNAN AND CLAPPER AND
COMEY DID.
NOT BECAUSE I AM GOING TO PUNISH
THEM.
YOU AM MAKE DETERMINATION.
>> Sean: SUSAN RICE.
>> I WOULD ALSO TELL THEM TO FIX
THIS.
WE CAN'T HAVE AN ELECTION WHERE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
INTERFERING WITH AN ELECTION AND
I THINK THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO
DO TO APPOINT A COMMISSION OF 5
OR 7 PEOPLE AND TOP NOTCH MEN
FROM PRIOR ADMINISTRATION AND
WOMEN AND SAY FIX THE FBI AT THE
TOP AND FIX THE CIA AND
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES AND WE
CAN'T ALLOW IT TO HAPPEN TO
ANOTHER PRESIDENTS OF THE UNITED
STATES.
TO HELL, SORRY JEFF, JEFF
SESSIONS AND ALL OF THE OTHER
PEOPLE.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> Sean: DON'T APOLOGIZE.
>> YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT SPIES
IN THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
FAIL WOULD FISA COURT.
THIS IS INCREDIBLE STUFF.
>> Sean: YOU TALK ABOUT THE
SPIES.
IT WAS NOT JUST ONE FISA COURT
JUDGE GIVEN PHONY INFORMATION
THAT WAS NEVER VERIFIED OR
VERIFIED AND NEVER TOLD THAT
HILLARY CLINTON PAID FOR THE
INFORMATION.
WHERE IS CONGRESS?
WHY WON'T CONGRESS BRING THESE
FISA JUDGES AND DEMAND WHAT THEY
FEEL.
>> UNLIKE THE DEMOCRATS, THE
REPUBLICANS SCATTERED LIKE RATS.
YOU HAVE CERTAIN REPUBLICANS WHO
ARE IN WITH THE DEMOCRATS
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO DESTROY THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY CANNOT GET OVER THE FACT HE
WAS ELECTED.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE SOMETHING
HERE SO GUESTS CAN REPEAT IT.
WE NEED AN ACCOUNTING OF WHAT
MR. BRENNAN DOES AND CLAPPER DID
AND BOOK SALES MAN COMEY DID AND
SUSAN RICE AND SAMANTHA POWERS
DID.
WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN TO THE
UNMASKING STUFF NOT BECAUSE WE
WANT TO GET EVEN.
WE NEED TO FIX THESE DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES.
>> Sean: IT IS NOT A JOKE.
IF WE DON'T FIX IT, WE LOSE OUR
COUNTRY.